[Music]
Brandon six
boy
sh
what is popping fam Monday morning
January 15th it's MLK Day Martin Luther
King day for those of you that didn't
know that's right it's the holiday but
here at thick boy we just keep on
keeping on only holiday we take off is
Christmas and
Thanksgiving then we
acknowledge Columbus Day which is Native
American day you get the picture we're
out here grinding uh what's up guys Mr
you guys had a eventful weekend uh which
I can't talk about right now but I
will that's all I
say you'll see it'll it'll be out there
um outside that man yeah everything's
good everything's good kiddo had his
first football gamer day straight after
that he had tryouts for his All-Star
team just that Dad life man just living
the dad life just straight up Dad life
I'm in bed by nine these days up at 4
that's cool um as far as fight news goes
uh you got UFC what what is it what is
the the Strickland duplic is UFC 297
yeah UFC 297 is the first big
pay-per-view of the year of 2024 UFC 297
I'm not going to sugarcoat this thing
I'm not going to put sugar all over your
wiener and tell you it's delicious this
is uh not the best card if you didn't
have the main event of Shan Strickland
and uh dupes this would be a bad Fight
Night straight up it'd be a bad fight
night so you know you're just paying for
the main event uh Arnold Allen most uh
uh most ofar is a good
one um it's it's tough I'm I'm trying to
be cool I'm trying to be positive it's
Monday it's a Martin Luther King day so
I'm trying to stay on the positive vibe
here but it's a it's a tough
pay-per-view the good news here's the
good news the main event is Sean
Strickland uh DDP also the good news is
uh there will be a live fight companion
with Mr Joseph Rogan and the legend
himself coming all the way from New
Jersey in Joey Diaz and then the the the
absolute best Eddie Bravo and myself
that will be live on Jr YouTube and then
uh will be upload to Spotify on Saturday
um at 7 pm Pacific time so make sure you
guys tune in to that it's my favorite
thing to do so that should be a fun when
I'll be in Austin for exactly one night
and then I will be back out there the
following weekend because I have two
shows that next Friday Saturday at the
Vulcan gas company the stepmother ship
and that Thursday before I'm in
Nashville for one night only two shows
in Nashville at zany so come get you
some tickets at thick boo.com let's sell
these [__] out all right uh but let's
get into the fights man um you got a
fight over the weekend again not the
best but still it was important fighting
the light heavyweight division maged
Johnny Walker uh been a frustrating
matchup I'm never a fan of when
something happens in a fight in I poke
groin so whatever and then they rebook
it I'm like I'm over it you know I'm
over it this one they just couldn't move
past they had to get it done to kind of
clear up the light heavyweight division
who's going to be the next Contender uh
magamed um took care of business he got
a huge finish over Johnny Walker um now
Johnny Walker versus Alex Pierre is a
much more sellable fight funner fight
but we're not going to see that so
maged I mean made it enticing by getting
a a big knockout with a KO punch so um
you know he feel bad for Johnny Walker
this was his shot who knows the light
heavyweight division's pretty slim so he
rips off two wins you're right back in
there but you know uh mamed I did not
think he was going to win via KO that's
for sure but he got it done so I would
assume he's next in line which is a he's
just a nightmare of a matchup for Alex
Pier unfortunately it's a bummer um
because I'm a big Alex fan so we'll see
what they're gonna do with that Jim
effing Miller got it done and then he's
uh campaigning to get on UFC 300 I
assume the UFC is going to do that they
need something positive for UFC 300
right now and you're out to your God
freaking love and mind if you think
300's in any facet is going to be better
than UFC 299 UFC 299 is so stacked that
thing is so tasty UFC 299 is so damn
good so again
300 you know I think the fans are used
to especially the hardcores who came up
you know where 100 was a big deal 200
was a big deal if you're new to the
sport you just got on board because Jake
Paul started talking about these guys in
you're a young Generation Z or whatever
the hell you call yourself you probably
have no expectations for 300 you're like
just a number it's not a big deal but
for the the hardcores the old heads out
there 300's a big deal UFC knows it's a
big deal to us so they're they're trying
to do their best to stack it I think
they're working with some elements that
are out out of their control with
Ramadan and you know when you look at
the actual star power of the UFC it's
not like it was back in the 100 days or
the 200 days then the one Mega star that
they have they booked later in
international fight week in Conor
McGregor and who knows if that even
happens so I think UFC is trying their
best Dan White's taking a lot of heat
right now you know obviously they
announced they're doing a bunch of
fights at they P Center which is
frustrating so I get why they do it from
a business standpoint and then also um
you know Dan White like I get a big
fight announcement and he announces the
the China on China fight uh with way
vers uh Yan so you know it's a great
fight but I just think if you've been
following UFC for a long time we just
expected more it's a great if they if
it's on UFC 299 298 297 could definitely
use the help uh 301 303 305 306 you're
like damn this is sick but we our
expectations are so high because they
haven't they haven't called out a big
fight like a a mind-blowing fight we
like oh my God this is insane we just
haven't had that yet a steepe Aspen an
aspen Pier um an Izzy winner of duplic
Strickland that could still happen
there's you know there's been Rumblings
of kabib which is hilarious you know I
started the rumor of uh Nick Diaz coming
back uh and GSP right um with no
credibility no just looking off his
Instagram that went you know Bonkers so
the khabib things because that's just
the hardcore is trying to figure out
like we're used to the UFC come up with
something like khabib even the khabib
thing I'm like you're out of your mind
that there's not a shot and khabib
cleared that up that's not happening um
I'm just curious you know if you're Bel
Muhammad and Leon Edwards what's the the
hesitant what's the hesitation there why
isn't that being announced for you
that's a shoe in for 300 now again that
is a great fight of two guys that should
be one's the champion defending Champion
the's below Muhammad who deserves it
more than anybody what's the hesitation
there there's something going on there
that's something that you guys should
look into or something you should focus
on there's a reason that match hasn't
been made something's going on there I
don't know what it is but that's there's
something some Mega fight there that
we're waiting on that they're going to
announce because the UFC knows for 300
if the main events Leon Edwards bah
muhamad that doesn't do it that doesn't
satisfy the the hardcore so there's
something going on there Izzy's also
going to be in town in Toronto um this
Saturday sitting ringside not hamzat so
that should be noted as well hamzat was
told he was guaranteed the next title
shot Dana's never said that publicly
Hamot saying that putting pressure on
the UFC it It's just tough CU he has one
middleweight win over merart who wasn't
even ranked at the time and he beat
Kamar Usman who's I'm an 85 now you get
a TI shot and again I hang off his Harry
dastani and chit and nuts I love H I
love me some Hamza I love him that is a
tough sell that is a tough sell B nickl
has more wins at middleway I'd Rather B
nickl get the shot or b nickel Hamot
fight even though they announced a b
nickel fight like come on let's go how
long we going to build this kid up so
UFC has something up their sleeve depend
how the Sean Strickland and DDP fight
happens you got Izzy ringside we'll see
Izzy had a court case for his DUI and um
one of their arguments was he can't work
if they're GNA in you know put in these
disciplinary actions so is that a you
know a nod to hey he's gonna fight soon
is he going to fight at 300 if you do
this he won't be able to fight you know
he's back training so I would assume the
the big nailbiter there would be Sean
Strickland DDP depend how it goes all
out War might be tough cuz UFC 300's in
what uh January February March April May
is it June I'll look her
now because the timing of
it April April so DDP and uh Strickland
fight in January so January febr March
it's a tough turn
around guys have done it and I know
Strickland would be down you know so if
Strickland wins I would I would assume
he get Izzy Strickland for UFC 300 that
would
be a big fight that would do it you know
or if Strickland wins you get Strickland
you know if he wins and he's not injured
you get Strickland Hamza maybe but
something's going on with Leon Edwards
Bal mohammd how how have they not
announced that theyve announced all
these big fights there's nothing there's
no Rumblings
isn't that weird I mean because
obviously it doesn't really sell that
well BL it sucks but I know that's
that's probably one of them you think
they'd still announce and put a title
fight because usually they stack the
title fights on the UFC 100 200 300
that's what they're known for so even
though that's not like this crazy fight
that's going he deserves it for sure
yeah he deserves it but it would also be
another title fight added to 300 yeah so
that's what we talk about you have way
who's fighting for a title all right
there's one you have B muhamad and Leon
there's two then that third one could be
Strickland Izzy could be Strickland
Hamot could be Strickland B Nichols or
it could be DDP DDP Strickland would be
the big Izzy the yeah DDP Izzy is the
one that the UFC's yeah in their mind
they like oh God I hope DDP wins so just
and not that they don't like Strickland
he's a bigger star than DDP but DDP
versus Izzy they can sell for 300 and
they're going to back up the Brinks
trucks for Izzy for that to happen in
April
so so the question is what happens on
Saturday's main event to me it's it's
the toughest fight in quite some time to
call usually these things I mean there's
it's MMA so you know nothing surprises
me anymore nothing at all these days
anything can happen there's too many
ways to lose a guy doesn't show up had a
bad cut he's tired whatever things
happen it's MMA there's a million ways
to lose so nothing surprises me but um
this fight is tough to call super tough
to call
um you know DDP and Strickland is a
fight where we'll learn early on where
if Strickland's going to win this fight
you know and it's five rounds which is a
huge advantage to Strickland his cardio
is absolutely insane his pace is insane
early on especially in the first second
round if Strickland can Imp in pose his
will and use his cardio and pressure to
get DDP on his back foot this is a good
sign if you're a Strickland fan so if
Strickland can dictate the pace he's
going to blow DDP out of the water if he
can dictate the pace just like he did
with Izzy just like he's done before and
avoid the big shot which I think he's
learned from the Alex Pier fight not to
play that game if he can control the
pace if he can continue to put DDP on
his back foot he's going to blow the
doors off DDP that's easier said than
done because this is a clash of styles
you have one guy that lik to apply
pressure like uh Strickland you know and
use that his pace and break guys down
and mentally break their will through
cardio they got DDP who doesn't really
go backwards he comes forward not the
most technical guy even though he is
technical it's like saying Gate's not
technical Gate's technical in his own
right DDP is awkward but for
his style it's very technical although
it doesn't look like it to the train eye
he's very very technical we saw in the
Whitaker fight so for DDP it's going to
be controlling Strickland's Pace getting
Strickland to go backwards not just
hovering around the cage once his foot
does go past that black line circling
out and turning around and kind of
imposing his power shots and you know
his will on Strickland so this is going
to be an interesting battle here because
both guys need to control the pace
whoever controls the pace wins the fight
nobody's better at controlling a pace
and changing The Narrative of a fight
than Shan Strickland so that's why I air
towards Sean stricklin in this fight
because besides Alex Pier he just breaks
dudes he breaks everybody so I just
think DDP is gonna have a hard time and
I also don't think not only the fan base
even if you're a big Sean Strickland fan
but just fight fans in general don't
realize how technically def defensively
good Strickland is so I do think he can
avoid the big shot from DDP now that
being said if DDP lands one in these 25
minutes it could be a short night for
for Strickland but I do think
Strickland's learned from the Alex beer
fight I think he controls the pace and I
think he melts DDP and I know ddps
coaches have came out and defended his
cardio before and said oh he had you
know nose surgery and he was at 5%
breathing capabilities but that is
something to make a note of that he's
not out of all DDP strengths and there's
a lot of them cardio wouldn't be in the
top five for Strickland probably number
one so when you have that vast
difference in cardio I'm going ear on
the side of the guy who went out there
and kind of
melted is he he's melted all these guys
man and I think he can do it to DDP he
just has to avoid that huge African bomb
you know that's just the number one
caveat there he has to be
smart and I I don't think people are
respectful of how godamn good Strickland
defensive boxing is and I think DDP is
going to learn and uh can he beat him in
the rematch yes but I think in this
first fight Strickland's so awkward and
just so damn good and there's only one
one way you learn that that's by being
in the Octagon by the time you learn it
it's too late you're in the fourth round
and he's melting your soul he's going to
break your soul the other thing to note
here is
we haven't seen Strickland
this he's not mentally broke but this
upset by Trash Talk usually if you look
at the wins and the guys are trash
talking even though he's having fun at
the press conference even with Izzy it's
never personal he he always he always
like you know he'll poke fun at guys and
have do his thing and we love him for
that but it's never that personal and we
don't seem upset this is the first time
we've seen Sean Strickland personally
offended you know you can see you know
they came sitting each other he's
fighting him so so is that an issue for
Strickland is Strickland at a
championship level where he that doesn't
affect his game he can still maintain a
a level head and not use you know this
anger to to trade shots with DDP
something to be you know something to be
said he definitely needs to and I'm sure
his coach Nick sick knows this you know
he he knows that Sean needs to fight
smart and and fight with his head and
not his heart and and you know because
DDP will make you pay so all that being
said I do have Sean Strickland winning
this fight I have him win this fight I
think he can TKO him in the fourth round
I would say it's a late TKO just because
the cardio he wears uh DDP down
eventually lands big shots and gets him
out of there or um it's via decision and
I think he you know wins four rounds
probably three three to four rounds I
don't think he you know pitches a shut
out because I I think that first round
he's going to feel him out he might not
be able to apply the pressure but as the
fight goes on as as we've seen with DDP
um his cardio is something you should be
worried about if you put money on him
when it comes to Strickland you know
again go back to DP there the Darren
tail fight you saw some cardio issues
the Derek Brunson won um you know
obviously with
the where was the one fight I'm thinking
of obviously with the Robert Whitaker
you know he
didn't have to show cardio there he
finished him early in the second round
so but the Derrick Brunson fight there's
some questions definitely the Darren
till the brat tarez um and when I see
that you know and not to mention he's
never gone five
rounds especially in the UFC as a main
event Sean shrick has been a much bigger
fights so all signs to me Point towards
Shan Strickland unless he gets caught
which can definitely happen but my money
would be on Shan Strickland I think we
need show him a little more respect I
think just going ah Izzy had a bad night
Strickland's not that good that ain't
going to work for me the kid's damn good
damn damn good can we bet on it yes oh
so I definitely take DDP yeah I get it I
get it and after DDP what he did to
Robert Whitaker it's it's nuts I can
definitely see you know I'm not
confident I'm not throwing 50 G's on
Strickland you know but yeah we can bet
it what do you want to bet lunch or 50
bucks let's do lunch at uh the place up
there all right cool sounds good lunch
case who you got I don't know I don't
know on this one this one's tough yeah I
can see both guys winning I feel like
you see a route to a victory for both
guys it may just be recency bias but I
also I feel like stri Strickland's going
to get it done it's just a feeling I
don't
know go to Strickland's record there
too I just Envision the DDP taking him
out like early like if he wins that's
how it's going down yeah if he wins it's
it's defin early it's first second round
big bomb you know as stri you know
stricken does lean back it's that big
bomb you know and I can see him trying
to
Grapple I think people are going to be
surprised with how good strickling
grappling
is yes strin just be melting dudes
though no he's a great Fighter for
sure if you take out Izzy let's say
you're a stricklin hater and you're
going to say who has Strickland beat his
strength of schedule who has Strickland
beat take out the Izzy win let's say
Izzy had an off night so all right your
excuse for him beating the greatest
middleweight of all time is is he had an
off night strling is not that
good before that he beat magedov he
melted that dude performance of the
night that light heavyweight short
notice imav he he beat the brakes off
him melted him but before that he had a
split decision loss where he didn't look
fantastic against Canon Aire and does
DDP beat Canon air I think
so and then he obviously got starched by
Alex
Pier his best win if you take out
Strickland
is if you take out Izzy yeah I'm sorry
we're talking about strick if you take
out Izzy his best win Would Be Jack
Lanson yeah but these are all like
pretty damn even IMA was good Joo is
good Brendan Allen
really good yeah he has like pretty damn
good wins yeah probably Brendon Allen's
the most impressive especially even
though that was four years ago was that
a catch weight yeah at 195 that's
probably his best win
right especially what Brendan's doing
yeah that's what I'm saying with the
surgeon Brendan Allen and then go to go
to a DDP I'm trying to compare strength
of schedule here Robert Whitaker KO
that's a big that's a big deal he's only
lost a man named Izzy that's the only
person that beats Whitaker and he
starched him Derrick brunson's a good
win he's a tough [__] customer Darren
till good win Brad tvar is good
win and the one guy he beat before and
then he lost before he got to the UFC at
ksw Roberto soldic the Croatian monster
from one Championship no punk that guy's
a Savage and he beat him he also lost
him but he also beat
him yeah you give strength of schedule
to DDP
especially the The Knockout one over
Robert
Whitaker yeah tough fight to call dude
right that's what makes it fun though
yeah I'm so excited for this I don't
even care about the rest of the card
there's not much Arnold Allen's a fun
one that's a tough fight for him and
your boy mag's on there yep Neil's on
there against M lot Chris Curtis is on
there man rest that card is
disgusting it's it's insult ins
in it's insulting right because well the
UFC knows they're in Toronto Canada
loves MMA they'll sell this thing out
even if you didn't have that main event
Raquel Penton and uh Silva could sell
this thing out in Canada UFC knows this
like we don't care you going to do [__]
you're gonna watch it's gonna sell out
it's t it's
Toronto speaking of Toronto speaking of
Toronto it's going down this Saturday
watch the fight companion live on JRE
YouTube with Joey Diaz Joseph Rogan
Eddie Bravo and myself and he can watch
it with us and also make some money M
money UFC 297 is
bringing the Reed says stacked fight
card to Toronto but we'll just say
they're bringing a fight card to Toronto
and throwing down on the action with
draftking Sportsbook the official sports
betting partner of the UFC we will take
your excitement level north of the
Border new customers can bet five bucks
and get 200 instantly in bonus bets uh
uh as I mentioned uh Strickland
DDP flip a coin take the bet there's a
reason why the odds are so close if I
were to put money on it I'd take Shan
Strickland via TKO if because you're do
a prop bet that's where going to make
money or St Strickland uh via decision
that's probably your best bet to Parlay
there take the props and then I think
arold Allen gets it done as well um
download the draftking Sportsbook app
with the code shop show that's SE show
new customers bet just five bucks on UFC
297 and get 200 instantly and bonus bets
only on draftking Sportsbook with a code
shop show the crown is yours gambling
problem call 1 1800 Gambler or visit
www.1 1800 gambler. net in New York call
8778 heny or text heny 467 369 in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call 888 78977 77 or
visit ccpg dog please play responsibly
on behalf of Boothill Casino and Resort
in Kansas 21 plus age varies by
jurisdiction void in Ontario bonus bets
expire 168 hours after issuance C dk.com
MMA for eligibility and deposit
restrictions terms and responsible
gaming
resources Ry oh oh oh o Riley Auto Part
and I'm going to be using them cuz I
might have messed up one of my vehicles
we'll have some news for you on that
very soon it's a disaster how long has
it it been since you total your truck
how long has it been since you changed
your spark plugs replacing your spark
plugs can restore efficiency and
performance to your vehicle right now at
O'Reilly Auto Parts get a $12 O'Reilly
gift card after rebate when you purchase
four or more select ACD AC Delco spark
plugs maintain your performance and fuel
mileage with the new spark plugs from
O'Reilly Auto Parts you can also improve
visibility with new wiper blades wish I
had those as well right now save 12 on a
pair of rainx rugged XL wiper blades
plus get two times o rewards points and
extra- llarge profile and premium
features make rugged XL blades the right
choice for extreme weather driving and
durability if you're an Iowa you
probably wish you had these right now
the professional Parts people will even
install your new wiper blades for free
if you're uh if you have no clue what
you're doing like Brian Ken have them
install it their wiper blades for spark
plugs to wiper blades and more save
right now doit right deals in store at
O'Reilly Auto Parts all you got to go to
is your local O'Reilly Auto Parts or go
to O'Reilly auto.com oh oh o
Riley Auto Parts last one Progressive
Progressive boy this is spot on today
speaking of insurance tell you what man
uh this episode of the shop show
Strickland DDP is brought to you by
Progressive Insurance all right um you
can call the shots on your auto
insurance enter the name Price tool from
Progressive the Name Your Price tool
puts you in charge of your auto
insurance by working just the way it
sounds you tell Progressive how much you
want to pay for car insurance then
they'll show you the variety of
coverages that fit within your budget
giving you options you can pick it's not
all Cookie Cutter let them know your
budget boom they figure out a plan for
you now that's something you want to
press play on right now it's easy to
start a quote you'll be able to choose
the best option for you fast it's just
one of the many ways you can save with
Progressive Insurance quote today at
progressive.com to try name your prize
tool for yourself and join the over 28
million drivers who trust Progressive
Progressive casual insurance company and
Affiliates price and coverage match
limited by state law
Progressive all
righty current events sure Bud uh so
since the fight that happened over the
weekend with Walker and Uncle I have
Uncle I have called out Alex P of course
and Alex said he wants Hill and then I I
guess uh Glover texer who's his coach
said he he wants he said uh soon with
anv like very
soon couldn't they could couldn't they
do an KV for UFC 300 because he didn't
get hurt that's true you do pier and
cive again is that a blockbuster no no
not right now at least I think it was
Johnny Walker and cive that's funner it
would be more fun for sure and he'll uh
he'll manager said that he's he's not
sure he's going to be done with that
Achilles injury injury and also the
lawsuit oh that's stuff yeah yeah so you
know so I don't it's tough but if he did
fight anive anive did mention that he
would not do any
takedowns which that's do you believe
that or not no I don't Ox like wait what
you do what everyone thinks it's fun in
games until you get in there and you're
with a world class kickboxer and you're
not a world class kick and they hit the
[__] out of you that'd be great though
yeah if you actually it's also a good
way to get a title fight UFC's like
really you're going to do takedown he's
like I promise H it
hike uh all right you already mentioned
this earlier but so I wanted to talk
about this a little bit the reason why
this rumor came out is because there's
like uh this audio recording of Javier
Mendes saying something like khabib
usually doesn't train with me unless
he's getting ready for a fight he goes
I'm not saying he's getting ready for a
fight but when he trains with me yeah
there's potential there he kept saying
that over but he came out and clarified
afterwards on Helen ye's thing because
it went viral and everyone's like
khabib's fighting yeah so he did say
with thez says khabib is back trained
with him for the first time since he
retired back in 2020 and gives update on
potential comeback he's always training
always trained but he's never trained
with me you understand he's been
training but he's never trained with me
only when he fights he trains with me
that I can tell you whether he fights or
not I don't know but he's training with
me so he can take that for what it's
worth
butar yeah yeah cuz I bet kabib called
him like Hey man yeah my my social media
is blowing up dude yeah so in this clip
I don't know I don't know what to play
but he just pretty much says like I
don't know how people are thinking this
is this he's never coming back he's
never going to fight again he well hey
man the time he trains with you is when
he's fighting so we're like all right I
wonder how long ago that clip was from
though too cuz I couldn't really track
it down but it might something new yeah
I don't know what's this white bashes
scumbag Punk Jones in 2014 text how'd
they get released oh uh because of the
what's that lawsuit the antitrust
lawsuit with the UFC so they're they're
you know opening up documents of texts
and stuff too so they damn they even
open up their text they when in that
wait that's not the one they popped
up that's from Jon Jones you said right
yeah uh yeah Dana Jon Jones yeah I have
that somewhere here too give me one
sec why you finally got to PE so
bad we're live dog
all right cool all right so me and case
you talk about we'll talk about it then
gosh we're live where you going we are
live yeah he's got a pee he's got a pee
then what do we talking about uh so
there's texts that were released because
you know during the anti antitrust
lawsuit there's like a discovery period
so you can open up this you know all
this all these bring old [__] from
2014 uh and then uh this is Dana White
basically talking to the FAS he says
what's up with Jones did he straighten
up or is he still being a scumbag he
asked the fertitas I guess fertitas
responded with still a douche but we're
inching closer uh haven't moved on money
but sent a letter with an ultimate him I
mean at the time that that's kind of
accurate I mean he was not the best yeah
yeah yeah so that's
yeah that's a legit thing that happened
has Jones responded I haven't seen
awesome let me see these
Texs back what's up baby uh this right
here it starts right here so it says all
pretty standard contract negotiation
stuff with white and fto seem pretty
personally offended by Jones uh so
what's up with Jones who's that from
Dana did he straighten up or is he still
being a scumbag okay and he put still a
douche but we're getting inching closer
haven't moved on money but sent the
letter with the ultimatum and then it
goes here awesome F that punk Lorenzo do
you have to say Lorenzo that's not nice
awesome F that punk Lorenzo he needs to
know we don't need him or he will F us
over more than he already does 2014
so yeah that's when Jones is going
through some stuff
right yeah yeah and then remember he
turned down the cha sonm fight in Canada
and then yeah um you know it's not too
bad yeah no it's just like stuff that's
just being released now because of the
the lawsuit he's saying way worse than
that you know that's not too
bad all right um let's go Motion
probably ran pretty high this is a
pretty cool fight sea Brady versus
Vicente luk poor Vicente luk right he's
supposed to fight our boy Ian Gary and
they went yeah it's not happening we're
going to push that oh and here's Shawn
Brady instead he's like what the f it's
a tough fight for
facente yeah that's a that's a really
good match up great match up great
matchup and we already discussed this
but yeah Zen Lee versus Jan Shan for UFC
300 like this should be in China why
isn't this in China shut up ah shut up
they'll be watching so it'll be fine
yeah trying to be watching not but
that's why it doesn't like blow my hair
back no and that's why when he he
announced it so many people had they
were like what what the hell well
because he's like I have a huge
announcement for UFC 300 here we go yeah
then he was like waye vers Yan World
cool all right thanks for that yeah oh
then we're also going to do a ton of
fights at the apacks Y okay sick yeah
anticlimactic for sure and then he
announced on Tuesday but then they said
they were busy so they did it on
Wednesday all of it was kind of a a
little bit of a mess but this is a cool
fight davidon figuro versus Cody Garber
great fight
yeah great fight Cody's on two fight win
streak God bless him hopefully he gets
gets it done against figero he asked for
this fight like this is a great fight on
UFC 300 still 300 not better than 299s
more 299 is TA T tasty bro in Miami that
thing is popping
popping like why would you just make UFC
2993 if nobody's complaining about 300
if it's the 299 card why would you make
299 better than
300 granted they're like we don't get
the and maybe it's just us who cares
about 300 maybe UFC is like it's just a
number we don't give a [__] anymore
using bite no matter what just be happy
with 299 it's like all right well can't
you just switch it over just to make us
happy like no we don't care but it's
their fault they set the precedent by
making 100 to 200 Big it's like now
we're expecting it you're living in the
past bro yeah you're right you see
different animal
now true I do feel Saturday's card is
just be honest with you
for $84.99 in HD or $79.99 what it is
about 80 bucks for sure though 80 bucks
terrible if that was a fight night you
like I might watch some of it take off
Strickland DDP oh yeah the rest of car
fight night like I like Arnold Allen
outside that like
you want you're not going to shut down
your
plans you're not going to not go to
Korean barbecue that is true yeah you
know you're still carry on like I'll
catch them later I'll record them it's
not like musty TV just that made event
yeah it is it's definitely heavy it's
rude yeah they have to have something
planned that that we just have no idea
what it is guarantee they do yeah
guarantee it so uh Brandon Marina was
supposed to fight Amir albazi but albazi
has like some sort of neck injury that's
a bummer cuz albazi is a tough customer
yeah but now he's fighting he's
rematching Brandon royval in Mexico City
for that fight R valal trying to fully
redeem
himself and this one came out of left
field this is crazy this is a mixed
rules fight yeah so special mixed rules
fight yoshihira akyama sexyama versus
Nikki holken who's wanted like you know
the best kickboxers yeah M guys what a
great super fight and here's the rules
it's kind of crazy round one will be
under boxing rules round two mu Thai
round three MMA I don't know if it gets
yeah I don't think it gets to three I
think by round two akiyama's bodies can
go from bronze to Blue bronze to Blue
you know yeah I don't know this is
that's dope though yeah and great poster
for sure this is aama's record as of
late obviously sha is not at his top
Peak Performance these days but he wants
that and he won another one against
Sheriff muhammd and then this is Nikki
holkins record as a l for
kickboxing okay so they're both fallen
on tough times yeah he beat our boy Jane
Wayne John son of a [__] that a tough
one but that's a cool I mean that's a
fun event like boxing the Muay Thai and
then MMA me tough for sexy G those first
two rounds very tough without a doubt uh
Rose namama junis remember she moved up
to flyweight so she's staying there and
she's going to fight on M that's a good
fight March
23rd that's a Fight Night Main
Event yes sir exactly why it should
be uh I'll just play this clip for you
this is Marlin Cheto Vera talking about
Cory San Haagen as a man as a real man
that I am and I qualify myself as I will
ask for San Haagen because he beat
me whatever they pick I would do but if
I have to choose myself I want to kick a
says I know his dorky ass is crying
about I know his dorky ass is crying
about it it's not my fault God how great
is cheo's hair right now my word I
thought he was I honestly thought he was
balding kind of but then when he grows
it out it's like full man it is that
thing is flourishing and it grows so
fast he looks great he looks so much
better like this than when he shaves his
head yeah man
hair that's what it does uh so there's
this funny thing where Anthony Smith was
talking to Michael bisbing and he says
he gives Jim Miller a 50/50 chance at
winning against Brock Lesnar obviously
it's for fun ABS so they asked Jim
Miller about it and Jim's like yeah yeah
I yeah I I think I could win too but he
says as a fighter the mentality you have
to think that way anyway agree that's
exactly what Jim Miller should say a CA
he's not he's not pulling off any
submission unless it maybe an anchor
lock something like that just curo
he yeah it's not happening you know how
big that arm is it'd be all of Jim
Miller's body just twerk on Brock fun to
talk about ain't happening what do you
think about him um his request for Bruce
Buffer for UFC 300 to say to call him
Jim [__] M effing Miller they should
definitely do it and it's like
pay-per-view so you can do it right yeah
you can do it's also the UFC where guys
have said the f word the other one that
rhymes with
rag you know it's the UFC dude they have
Tucker Carls and Donald Trump cage side
what's an F bomb from Bruce Buffer the
great Bruce Bruce Buffer yeah that'd be
so
epic also would barely make news it's
the UFC it would be so Strickland DDP
fought in the crowd yeah and they they
use that they put in HD remember they Ed
their good HD they good cameras they
have all these like YouTubers which is
basically I you know we let's talk about
this we've never seen this in any other
league people should know what's going
on the the hardcores know what's up
you've been around long enough
do you real they're they're doing the
UFC is doing what the White House is
doing when when they have those
briefings and they have select media
members no one that's going to ask like
challenging questions at least the White
House allows one guy from Fox to be like
hey what about this with Biden or the
you know border control and then they
just like shut him down and move on to
somebody who's going to ask you know the
softball questions what the UFC has done
so the Anti-Trust law doesn't get
brought up is they kick out anybody like
a IR helani or Luke Thomas who's going
to ask those tough questions so the
narrative doesn't get out there so
they've replaced all them and they've
just inserted like YouTube personalities
the elk boys insert whatever young kid
who just got into MMA two days ago so
they have those guys as their media
members who don't have a clue about
antitrust about the the past you know
disgruntled it Fighters they they don't
have a any history of the UFC they're
just in the moment going oh man what a
great fight card in Toronto this is
insane you're doing this for us I love
the Apex slap fight's my favorite when's
Mark Zuckerberg gonna fight so they've
eliminated anybody who's gonna go quick
question what are we gonna do about this
anti- lawsuit looks like it's getting
steam have you heard anything because
you do they go uh next question get him
out of here he they never come back so
now if you notice and again I don't know
if I'd do any different if I was a
business I get it but notice there's no
like legit journalist anymore in there
it's all these vaping YouTube you know
it's it's it's that weird mix of because
they bring a fan base this young fan
base with them you know they're like
whoa did you see that uppercut you know
like they have no clue what's really
going on oh power slab these athletes
are insane you know like that's what the
UFC wants there's nobody who's going to
question authority there's nobody hey
this matchup you promise you say don't
make fights after fights yet you keep
making
fights they have no context of
historical context of what the UFC is
about how became the UFC so it's just
these like
softballs it's just these softball
questions oh I'm so great to be here man
uh Jon Jones Brock Lesnar we ever going
to see that it's like what are we doing
how's this moving the ball towards the
goal line but that the UFC wants to
control the N they're the best at it I'm
not hate shunning him for it I'm just
saying pay attention what's going on
notice you're not getting Luke Thomas
Ariels banned from there Luke Luke's not
in there the real hardcore guys who have
been around a long time are going to
have some questions you're not seeing
any of that so I I agree with that for
sure but also the the two guys that I
would say kind of like get to the edge
of it like the threshold of it is Kevin
ioli and John Morgan they kind of ask
you know like tougher questions but
they're not going too far and also they
again just like the White House the they
know what's up yeah and again that's
what pays their bills like why would you
if you're either of those guys why would
you ask that antitrust you know if you
bring up antitrust law you're out dude
your credentials are out you're you're a
helani you're out you're never working
another event again so I'm not saying
they should I'm just saying so you have
those journalists there and they're
playing the game and then you have all
these like cupcake YouTubers who like oh
quick question that uppercut was nuts
right d he like sure was next question
well this thing was sold out man this
thing's packed to the gills how's that
make you feel I feel good next question
like what is happening right now
nobody's gonna ask any of these
questions nobody you know yeah it's a
tough one man you don't lose no
journalist going to ask about the usada
what happened there with Conor coming
back the the crazy testing the new test
it's they control everything now but
there's no legit journalism there's no
push
back yeah those days are gone I get it
you have to play the game the White
House does the exact same
thing you you got to control the
narrative here what it is you also
control your own destiny if you're
selling merch that's why there's Shopify
it's so easy all because I started with
Shopify that's right CH Ching all right
they got it done whatever you're selling
Shopify is the global Commerce platform
that helps you sell at every stage of
your business from the launcher online
shop stage stage to the first real life
store stage all the way did we just hit
a million ORD stage Shopify is there to
help you grow whether your auction
autograph apparel selling Sleek skis
whatever it is Shopify helped you sell
everywhere from their allinone
e-commerce platform to their in-person
POS system whatever when whatever you're
selling wherever shopify's got you
covered Shopify helps you turn browsers
into buyers with the internet's best
converting checkout up to 36% better
compared to the other Commerce
platforms all right Shopify Powers 10%
of all e-commerce in the US and
shopify's Global force behind all birds
rothis and Brook lenon and millions of
other entrepreneurs of every size across
175 countries plus shopify's extensive
help resource are there to support your
success every step of the way because
business that grow grow with Shopify
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com shopall
lowercase all lowercase go to
shopify.com SL Shob all lowercase now to
grow your business no matter what stage
you're in shopify.com shopall lowercase
Ching happy hippo new code oh new year
new code it's happy hippo the best
creatum on planet Earth the only company
I ever freaking trust I reached out to
them because I use creatum every
freaking day whether I'm doing standup
podcast and working out your boys on
that crom but I'm only on that happy
hippo Crum they got K dips it's
basically like pouches if you dip but
it's katum they got the powders gummy
Taffy whatever form you want to try
creatum in we got you covered delicious
flavors they have the highly
concentrated uh shots you together the
energy shots butterscotch sour apple we
got it all for you go to happy hippo.com
promod is thick with three C's 24 that's
thick 24 for 20% off all right we got
you man it's thick 24 happppy hippo.com
for the best creatum on planet Earth
you're
welcome oh this one I'm excited for this
one I'm excited for we talking about
cage the elite supplement brand the
super Elite if you're in the UFC if
you're in professional sports or you're
just a dad kicking ass caged is the best
supplement that's ever touched these
lips this stuff is proven to work it's
thirdparty tested for baned substances
NS NSF informed Sports certified all
right so you can trust what's in the
bottle take all the guest work out don't
worry about what's in the bottle cuz
it's third party t tested for baned
substances NSF informed Sports certified
that means if you're in the UFC with
strict testing if you're in some
bodybuilding competition with strict
testing if you're in freaking the NFL
NBA NHL you can use cage supplements you
can depend on cage these are the best of
the best caged separates itself from the
rest of the competitors they have clean
formulas no colors or flavors from
artificial sources patented key
ingredients never gen generic
alternative for examp example if you're
using a pre-workout product they're
going to say oh we have all this
caffeine in all but it's it's synthetic
caffeine it's not good for you cage has
pure calf organic caffeine what's in the
bottle is in the freaking bottle take
all the guess work out of it my absolute
favorite how I got hooked on cage is the
Pre-Workout Elite I use it every morning
before workouts um and then their mind
set there's a lot of M products out
there I challenge anybody to try mindset
and tell me there's a better product on
the market we talked about the Limitless
pill this a limitless powder it is by
far the best supplement for your brain
for your focus for podcasting for just
getting in the zone every single time
this is the real deal Holyfield you I
will guarantee you anybody out there
find a better product for your mind
there's a lot of stuff out there I've
advertised mind stuff before nothing
touches mindset this how I got connected
with cage it is the best product I've
ever ever tried from my brain mindset
Elite is insane every morning I have a
little scoop of that I have a little
scoop of the Pre-Workout Elite and your
boy is of and running a lot of people go
how do you have so much energy you do
all these shows how do you do this
maintain your life schedule your
business schedule being a dad I'm
telling you a lot of is due to CAG
straight up a lot of it's due to cage so
um the stuff works the science speaks
for it itself third party tested don't
worry about any of that stuff when
you're talking about cage they're
they're for you if you're ready to train
harder live healthier and become the
strongest version of yourself cage is
for you all right all you got to do is
go to cage.com that's k a d.com use the
code sha SE a you get 20% off mindset
the the Pre-Workout hydration Elite they
got protein all right these statements
have not been evaluated by the Food and
Drug Administration this product is not
intended to diagn no treat cure or
prevent any disease it's just made to
get your mind right to get your body
right it's 2024 a lot of you have
resolutions trying to get in shape I'm
telling you let cage be that partner for
you let them carry you on your journey
and you will not regret it cage.com K
with a cage k a d.com promo code is shop
for 20% off the best supplements
ever awesome all right Isam makev posted
this on x his plan so June 8 UFC
pay-per-view versus gatei November UFC
MSG versus oliv ver or Arman whoever
wins CU when's Ramadan start it changes
every year right I don't know when is
Ramadan I mean take my money g m i I'll
watch that all
day March 20 March 10 to April
9 so March April May June yeah so he'll
have a full Camp if fights in June and
then obviously he can fight in November
yeah I like mv's play there gatri Mev is
so much more exciting than Charles Oliva
we've seen that yeah uh serukan is the
one you want to see that that's the
fight I you know I think he beats gatei
pretty easily um but the serukan one
they fought before is you know first
fight in the UFC there's a lot of
history there suian and mo so much
better like that's the fight at 55
that's the freaking
fight
definitely a fun fight um so Mark hunt
was on MMA hour and he said that he was
recently offered to fight somewhere in
Australia and to throw it for like a few
million dollars like that actually came
to his table he didn't take it obviously
do they know who Maran is I mean it's
like asking Diaz bro to throw a fight
these guys for a few million dollars
it's like yeah and he said he could have
really used the money too but he didn't
take it so great on him so they would
only give him the money if he through
the fight what if he knocked the guy out
out he doesn't get paid no he can't he
can't do that oh build trying to build a
guy so he goes I've always been one that
says if things aren't right they aren't
right I was offered three or four
million do to take a dive in a fight
here in Australia and I said are you
serious I said no because that's just
not me although I could have done with
the money I was going to through some
hard times with separation and crap crap
but I could have done with three or four
million doar it's just not my character
it's not me I'd rather just go out on my
shield and then lose or die but that's
not what I'm about yeah that that would
be the last guy you approached and th
Mark hunt do they not know the fight
business there's a few guys like yeah
maybe throw that his way Mark hunt what
are we doing it's Mark freaking hunt
it's crazy it's still happening though
oh yeah yeah people are still asking uh
so Mikey musi posted this uh not too
long ago three days ago so there's a guy
who's a YouTuber I guess he started off
as a streamer he's very popular but he's
hated I guess he was making fun of Mikey
musi he said like people that do
jiujitsu are autistic something like
that and so this is what Mikey did
afterwards let me see about bullies
bullies are weak people that make fun of
others around them that give themselves
relevance and make themselves feel good
they pick on the differences of humans
which is the most beautiful part of
humans their uniqueness I really don't
like bullies guys and there's this guy
named sneo making fun of it making fun
of my friend making fun of Jiu-Jitsu he
calls himself a boxer I'm a jiujitsu guy
let's have an MMA fight I challenge ni
to an MMA fight I'm going to shut his
mouth and I'm going to take the bullly
lunch money today I'm going to talk so
he challenged that guy sneak
and the sneo guy said like yeah I do
boxing a little bit of boxing but he
would Mikey would still win no matter
what if it's MMA cuz you know he would
grab his leg or something like that I I
mean yeah Mike Floyd Mayweather does B
listen listen hold on hold on Tyson Fury
does boxing Anthony Joshua does boxing
Fran and G does boxing Mikey would beat
all of them in an MMA match you know how
good he is at Jiu-Jitsu this the sneo
kid why why sneo hated uh I guess he
just talks a lot of crap so he he
started off as a streamer then he
started doing commentary on YouTube but
I just I guess he just talks a lot of
crap yeah and so he was kicked off
multiple platforms too but uh yeah
anyway Mikey challenged him he's not
taking the challenge so it's cool that M
Mikey stood up for someone being a bully
but then sneo did say like that's what I
do for a living I just talk smack it's
just kind of like you know that's the
that's the nature of kids today like
this young audience like no I just talk
smack I'm not actually trying to back it
up
mhm and speaking of one Championship
they're going to be back in the US with
two know
this back at ball arena in Denver
Colorado baby although last time they
were at um Broomfield Event Center they
sold that bad boy out so they're
stepping their game up they're at the
ball Arena that's where the Nuggets play
ever heard of them world champion
nuggets that's September 6 then November
8th they're at State Farm Arena Atlanta
there'll be some big boy fights I know
that for a fact big boy
fights yeah it should be
fun uh this is a little clip of Daniel
cormi and all I got from this was
apparently one of Daniel's students one
of his wrestling students he didn't want
to you know show sportsmanship and shake
hands so Dan you can see Daniel here
kind of just watch pushing
him to
go he's saying you shake his hand and
then Daniel does shake this guy's hand
right here yeah yeah he was not having
it this guy said don't care if it's DC
or not you you don't touch my child like
that really what are you gonna
do I mean that was just like come on
pushing towards like you know to shake
hands he's not hitting him or anything
he not hit he's the kids obviously you
know like that's a good lesson to learn
the kid's not four you shoving them down
you
know uh Jon Jones was in California
recently so you know he already has his
pet tour but he had to go get some stuff
removed good time to do it it's good
time to do it now but when he comes back
he just full strength and this is you
know smart yeah so might as well get it
done while he can't yeah
exactly uh okay let me play this clip
real quick hold
on I guess this is from Karate combat
and then this is just some fight that's
happened in the stands and then someone
tried to film
Arlovski is that our L key throwing
oh they try to film and he just like get
that camera out of my face and just
knock this yes I did don't stick your
phone in my face yeah or else you don't
mess around yeah and I think this is
going to be the last
one this is just funny this is uh Johnny
Walker with the little belt on his hand
and he says it's pretty cool let Johnny
Walker try his belt
on that's funny
yeah yeah I think that's it dude all
right brother we did all the reads we
did all the reads right yes yes all
right you got big pay-per-view going
down this freaking Saturday Sean
Strickland DDP it's going down I got
Strickland but who freaking knows these
days make sure you tune in JRE fight
campaign with Joseph
Rogan Joey Diaz Eddie Bravo and myself
and then the following week I will be
back in Austin but the torque the keep
on trucking tour kicks off in Nashville
that's next Thursday two nights at zany
in Nashville and then Friday Saturday uh
I will be in Austin Texas that's at the
Vulcan gas company stepmother ship in
Austin Texas January 2 6 27th get your
freaking tickets Nashville and Austin
next week tour kicks off keep on
trucking get your tickets at thick
boy.com enjoy the fights this weekend
like subscribe love you guys stay safe
out there see you next
week